today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza
Ridge wallet Ridge wallet there have
been moments in your life where you're
standing around and you're like oh man
my pants are so heavy in the back maybe
it's because of this girthy girthy
girthy fat thick wallet I got and people
are looking at you and thinking oh man I
got got that six or seven pound wallet
it must be heavy must be hard on his
back hard on a spine
well now you can change that all with
the front pocket carry the ridge wallet
it's a wallet that goes in your front
pocket you can keep your money your
credit cards your identification things
that are very important get rid of all
the drunk downsize that butt hump change
it up no more that back door back deal
get rid wallet that front pocket carry
go to Ridge wallet calm /t PW and use
code hitter at checkout for 10% off
that's code tpw for 10% off at Ridge
wallet dot-com /t p W go on ahead and
get that front pocket carry today's
guest is the author of the wolf of Wall
Street
I guess that's an autobiography he is
notorious I think is a good word to
describe him he also is the host of the
wolf's Dan podcast it is the wolf of
Wall Street
mr. Jordan Belfort
[Music]
what's the largest or most like the
largest woman you think ever made love
to it's not even how large it was
oh and when I was high I made love to a
240-pound woman with [ __ ] beard
probably because when I'm on coke I'll
[ __ ] anything or eat anything you know
ugly the better but when I'm knowing
saying okay it's time to how fat there
it's the size their ankles oh really
if they have thick ankles like I
couldn't get there's no viagra in the
world that could do the trick now is it
is an intimidation you think cuz the
like is it like my penis is like the
girth of kind of my penis won't be able
to compete with that no no it's not that
it it I'll just say that it might be
that like four levels down right but
there's just something about the look of
it that I don't know it just it just
[ __ ] scares me it's like it's like
I'm I'm trying to sleep with the
abominable snowman
what does it feel like an impossible
feat maybe I don't know it just feels
like they just like it's like I'm like
dude sorry dude [ __ ] with a guy I
don't even saying I'm right about it
like no you're right the guy down the
road who loves that yeah it's just it's
just a personal preference you know Oh
some guys get more into like yes bigger
girls you know stopple girls I liked it
I liked the Finn model type it oh yeah
yeah whatever
it's all about you know I guess back in
the 1800 used to like the have you girls
were more in vogue that means they were
fed better they were better bred yeah
but you know so for the rubenesque yeah
I remember when I was young I go to the
library and instead of uh this before I
got any good pornography you know we're
on the podcast because it's a pot yeah
what were you like yeah
oh dude this is great this is [ __ ]
fabulous is the real us right oh yeah I
said I'm not the [ __ ] I'd and I say
anything I'm glad that I [ __ ] went
missing I thought we're missing all this
stuff cuz though I think it's cuz I'm
you know listen I think the problem
nowadays is that people scared to be
honest when that [ __ ] drives me crazy
yeah and and and I'm and I'm BS you know
I said that about girls would think I'm
not saying I'm right and you're saying
it less beautiful I'm just saying to me
yes everyone has their type that's white
whatever reason might have dropped to my
head as a kid
who knows well maybe I did couldn't get
it up once with a guy like that and it
deep wounded me forever or maybe I just
don't like girls without the ankles yeah
but I that's that's the defining feature
for me oh it's interesting yeah you know
it's funny hundred fiber thought about
like you have a like what is like a
defining my given to drill a dealer do
not cross line for you with a girl or a
guy I don't I don't judge men do ya know
I never been in I never been in any kind
of sex with a man or anything like that
dude one time me and this guy was doing
a little bit of coke but thankfully had
to go to the airport you know cuz I
thought things might have got a little
wild but I think that thing in gay I
think you ever made I think it's great
so like I I'm really so I'm liberal like
that but I yeah I love guys I get a
little much better with guys I just want
to [ __ ] them yeah I wish it's like a
gift if I did it'll be is to play around
tenants don't [ __ ] do be amazing may
be crazy but I just don't like that but
I know I think it's awesome oh yeah I
think if guys I mean I've thought about
that like what if yeah you're you and
your buddy or like just you know playing
a game of hoops and then you know
Lackner you watch black mirror on
Netflix I haven't seen it I've seen the
new season okay that was just came out
right and there's an episode about these
two guys two black dudes right they're
best friends and one guy gives his
friend like a present for his birthday
and it's just like you know next next
next generation don't want official
reality will you put a little thing on
your head and you're actually in the
game and it's like all these old karate
games they used to play is when they
were like you know oh yeah yeah yeah and
and then you know you know the kicking
of punch right except now you're
actually in the game and his best friend
plays and it's the guy from who plays on
Red Wing from Iron Man from the from the
Avengers it's him he's one of the actors
it plays a Robert Downey no no Morgan
Freeman no who plays the aunt Red Wing
the guy with the wings who got flies
around Oh black a great actor amazing
actor not Don Cheadle who plays uh who
uh Denzel Washington no no no no it's
named uh [ __ ] not swaggy Peter he's not
a basketball players no no no no no the
guy who plays Red Wing in in the vengers
not not the oh I knew who it is Anthony
Mackie yeah yeah he was in uh he was in
the movie about the plane crash with the
football team yeah so so um dude he's in
this with another one great another
great actor in this in this blackberry
episode
and and what happens is what his friend
plays in in the game he's a girl or like
a hot kung-fu expert okay and he's just
young and young like in their 20s and he
thinks that his friends because I didn't
start fighting and they start [ __ ]
they start his friend just goes and kiss
that [ __ ] when they fall in love
inside the video game but their man on
the outside that aren't in love and on
the inside their man and then then the
guy it starts to [ __ ] up and sees a
happily married with a kid that's
[ __ ] up her sex life because he falls
in love in the game with this artificial
girl see he cuts it off and his friend
is devastate his whole [ __ ] family
and he can then you know whatever they
said because he can't deal with it right
because wife thinks having an affair
yeah and then finally he separates out
the whole thing
finally six months later they get back
together and he has a big fight with the
guy and his wife's like what's what's
going on it's going I'm and he finally
comes clean with his wife and then and
then the Blackmer thing ends with his
wife going out on a date with some other
guy in a bar and but has agreed and he's
having sex what I'd like to have a woman
week a month they get to [ __ ] that
little dalliance be out and about there
you go did you want do you think the UFC
would be cool if after somebody beats
somebody they had to insert themselves
and no I don't think so I not I think it
would be pretty tough it was a forcible
insertion because I think they call that
rape but I think it was it would be a
great difficulty to party and to the
right they go pH I think it'll be a
different type of sport yeah you think
you'd have survived you are sick [ __ ] by
the look I'm Ryan goes like I'm worried
about you because you're Michael I wish
I would have thought of that myself I'm
[ __ ] envious and right that's not
saying you don't bring your breakage it
up with a level level here you know you
bring you're sick [ __ ] to a sick [ __ ]
fight you know what I'm saying dude you
just put a gun to a [ __ ] slow
[ __ ] Oh bro if I'm talking to
you I'm bringing a Rousey to a bus fight
yeah but do you climb hit my wife honey
whatever it is now is off-limits it's
like I didn't really mean it was nothing
so [ __ ] different guy acting you go
and do you think that it would be a
different type of sport what's the next
level of sport that you think you see do
you start to Hunger Games I think
obviously you I'd well I think like in
in society oh really in society yeah
good question the next level up from UFC
you know here's the thing on on some
level
I loved the first UFC when there was no
rules no weight classes
nothing bar and except basically I think
you do almost anything but gouge
someone's eyes I may be or tell that
what tickle right what are the other
right I know which one is worse if you
ticklish but that would be that to me
that was pretty [ __ ] cool but people
they were they were saying was like Tom
does gladiate illegal so it was very
smart on the part of you have seen to
sort of sanitize the sport by putting
weight classes on certain rules and
guidelines to make it not a [ __ ] free
roll but I kind of like the free from
the problem was was that it turned out
that Brazilian jiu-jitsu just trumped
everything so the guy so if you went
into the ring knowing Brazilian
jiu-jitsu just [ __ ] Chunkin I wish
that yeah you know yes that was a
problem so they eventually had to have
some differentiator that but they but
also people skilled up in other words
that most people came in like I'm a
great boxer I'm a great like Taekwondo
God what did it matter if you knew Jitsu
just [ __ ] you use a mission hold
someone right right but once but then
you could not become a be quite as good
as the next guy but good enough to
defend against that if you were great at
boxing and these people get knocked out
with boxing so that became you know that
something was more than the weight
classes that changed they made more
interesting was like sort of the idea
that you could defend against jiu-jitsu
do it a basic level proficiency yeah
right did you ever uh did you ever take
any like boxing or Marceau everything I
did but not not sir I did yeah I did
it's okay but it wasn't called that I
wrestled in college okay
I took some karate never got past like a
yellow belt or something right yeah oh
yeah I wrestled pretty seriously so okay
did you whenever you went to prison do
you feel like what do you win when you
were going in there do you have a
thought in your head like [ __ ] I wish I
knew a little more self-defense just cuz
man that was a no cuz I what happened
was with jail prison
sorry jail no one spoke no the jails
referred to like is a short term local
local in prisons like when you go off or
I was actually to prison right
so wait were you actually going federal
one's longer try so I was I was no way
can yeah it depends I was lucky right
and I go to a place that was had no
violence or anything so it depends on
how many it's a point system right I was
a first-time offender with zero almost
like as low points as you can get so
there was no chance I was going
somewhere where there would be physical
violence and there was never physical
violence so and I knew that I knew that
going in Wow yeah so you did you think
like what was your biggest looking back
on Jill what's something that you
probably missed the most you think being
in jail yeah um I have one thing that I
listen Tommy Chong was my bunkmate yeah
he's actually coming my podcast tomorrow
really that's awesome I used to see him
at the gym sometimes we have the same
train amazing guy great guy lover but
yeah but I think there's only one thing
of about Jail that it was not that was
great it was the fact that I had nowhere
to go but up in other words I was at a
point there was an absolute bottom low
and there's some power in in a low if
you know you're the sort of person that
is gonna come back from that so far
worse is the time before jail when
you're waiting to go you can't restart
your life so it was like being there was
almost this cleansing period of your
spirit your soul and that's what your
body but I guess you're my guy that
worked out like a maniac I got amazing
shape prison Jack their prison [ __ ] oh
my god I was when I was you ripped just
[ __ ] rips you know and and I taught
myself to write when I was in prison so
I made the most out of my time but I
missed that feeling of like you know I'm
I was so anxious to come out like you're
looking forward to with that get started
yeah you're ready to get started so kind
of like a horse in the gate yeah do you
do you feel like while you're in there
that like does it feel like you can't do
you feel like you have apologies to make
you feel like you or do you kind of do
all that stuff before you go away to
prison like colleges to them the people
if you love all people you don't know
which anybody like yeah like if there's
any like um you know I had a long time
to prepare what do you like that yeah
years to prepare although you never get
fully prepared but of course when I was
there I mean you know I think this to
two things can happen in prison zone you
could go into prison and I mean like
they get a gladiator school you come out
even a bigger criminal because you okay
well this will hang on I'm gonna so see
the list or you can use it as all I did
is a period to learn and grow and get
stronger emotionally strong physically
strong with
like all the exercising but um but
really I came out I'm a far stronger
person in terms of emotionally and also
skill sets I I taught myself an
incredibly valuable skill which was to
write and that served for everything
that came after it yeah and so do you
feel like because I mean obviously you
would you consider yourself like one of
the most like notorious salesmen well
never it not would not know when I think
before 2008 I would say yes but once you
know everyone realized what was really
going on on Wall Street then I I started
to say well you know Kay like I'm not
gonna I wouldn't say that there's no
there's no one doesn't make what I did
less bad but I didn't bankrupt Iceland
or Greenland or Greece right and I did
not do what Bernie Madoff did and I do
think there are levels of apps nothing
is black and white so while what I did
was wrong for sure and I'll try to
minimize that it was paled into
comparison is what happened in the
global financial crisis with things like
Lehman Brothers and Goldman Sachs where
they literally bankrupted the world
economy almost were you envious at all
of those people and a little bit you
know
no that wasn't not to put that I would
have been in his ten years earlier but
at that point I had complete change my
value system and I felt more like I felt
more like you see not that I'm a not a
bad guy I wasn't a bad guy back then but
I always said this it wasn't like a see
I knew this was gonna happen for years
and years I know what was going on I
wrote about in my book in 2006 or
something I said right I wrote about
much before that and uh and um but was
like I did it just to me it was more
about like you know what get Nate and
there you have it and and even then it
wasn't like most of Wall Street was bad
Wall Street's a weird place you know
things get magnified one little thing
that wouldn't have much impact on the
outside world as a massive impact on
Wall Street you know right so do you uh
is Wall Street even a place where people
like it can the can the mom-and-pop
person somebody sitting at home like a
regular guy is there still any real
opportunity for people like that in in
the stock market percent there is very
simple take your money and put it in a
fixed fund that you just they just
invest in the essence
and don't buy it or sell it it's a it's
an electronically traded fun where you
know there's no buying and selling no
Commission's they just matching the SP
that's what Warren Buffett puts his
money so that's where I'd put in - where
I recommend you put yours do you uh do
you ever like long for the days of like
like I mean you know you watch wolf of
Wall Street right and so do you ever
long for some of the like is there
anything you miss the most about like
that I seemed like there was such a
sense of camaraderie even in some of
those sales yeah yeah I mean I'm I have
that now again and it's a thousand times
better the mistake that I made is what
you before you linked up but in really
really driving you linked up sales and
being evil and they're just complete
unrelated elements there's mom I am one
of the greatest salesman ever in history
and I created a Sales System wave
training salesperson that allowed that
insanity to happen right but that was
neither good nor bad it's you know it's
like a powerful weapon you up either
could use it for good or it could be a
mother in our house and five you know
rapist come in to kill her in a kids and
she know that guns a really great thing
what use being used very justly right so
you could use war you could use in from
a bell tower and knock out innocent
civilians on the ground right any
powerful weapon or any powerful
instrument can be an instrument for good
or evil
there's no absolutes so sales is exactly
like that if you're a great sales person
using sales and persuasion ethically
then you're getting people who need
things and have certain lacks in their
life to helping them fill those these
elegantly so they can live a better life
if right so you were a powerful weapon
for sales I was and and when I was in my
twenties I didn't use that ethically
always and now I would never do anything
but everything about my life is about
ethics and it and and and which is why
now I had that and it feels a million
times better so you get to act some
actual inner reward that was my mistake
it was an error of not judge just it was
something I had it wrong and that's my
definition of success back in my 20s was
about how much money can I make every
scores how that's natural and and it
happened then I learnt from and I
learned the hard way many people don't
have to learn white is hard aways all I
do but I learned to homie that's not the
truth now I have a much healthier
outlook on it so I use the gifts I had
no system I crave for the exact opposite
you know reasons which are reasons of
good do you feel like the
like your ability to be a great
salesperson or the ability to to
articulate to to lead to control I don't
want to say like to deceive but to to do
you feel like lo ensue influence yeah
that you feel like that those are like
you were born with those things yes or
do you feel like those are things that
you that you learned yes both yes to
both so I was born in the same way that
Michael Jordan or LeBron James in their
universe of what they do better than
anyone the world I was born with a in a
you know the skill given from God or
nature whichever one you believe right
and then through years of practice and
repetition I own that to near perfection
so I think and I think that's true of
everyone were all born with certain
skills and either we can develop them or
not the good news is with selling is
that you can learn you can become good
enough at it so it never hold you back
in your life I'm not saying I could turn
you into me but I can certainly take
someone who is having problems at work
with a community let's take a new sales
let's just say communication there make
their thoughts or ideas their hopes
their dreams known to other people in a
way that lets them say I get it I wanted
one right if you lack that one skill
it's really hard to succeed in life
because you know you're almost like a
one-person army so your buddies amazing
people out in the world that had these
great ideas they could have these
amazingly bright brilliant high-level
lives but they live a small life and a
far less expansive life and they could
because they they lack this ability and
they know it and their brain says you
know I don't really want to put myself
out there they don't feel comfortable I
probably won't even succeed anyway so
they down regulate their life they lower
their own personal standards and they
live a life it's not really as great as
it could be and I think that's the
beauty of what I do is I is the system I
created really helps between really
helping did you see somebody in you when
you were young in your life that had
that or something that made you think
like you know in hindsight look looking
back like oh that's not what I want or
they they they're they're cornered by
this affliction of their inability to
like own their own potential or to of
course my parents they had that yes
been in space left parents so my parents
I grew up in a lower middle class
parents were brilliant hard-working
education educated employed and broke
hmm that's like what the [ __ ] I'm like
whoa what what's missing from this but I
don't get it with my mother there said
how could people be so smart so
hard-working so industrious so loyal so
educated and have no money and the
answer is a they were risk-averse
completely risk-averse depression-era
mentality and second they thought that
selling was evil they thought that it
was inherently evil and because of that
that's your belief then you will shy
away from anything that makes you you
know we've even put you in that box of
being deemed as a salesperson so becuase
that they were both CPAs they never try
to sell their skills love the people
they work for the people they were cogs
in a wheel fortunately I made my dad
very wealthy he worked for me and um and
then things ended up oh well for them
but if it wasn't they would have never
lived the lives they were really in
terms of you know and by the way yeah
and live delights because without money
life's [ __ ] I want to live
yeah cause when you're older I mean your
social security stuff the baby your
diapers when you're really old you know
I'm sayin so they were able to you know
put away a lot of money and be okay did
they change you think like their
mentality and stuff changes they saw you
start to make more money do you think it
is justly not right no do you think it
adjusted their worldview or something at
home no they were such to this very day
they're still alive
that's 88 years old my mom's 86 and they
still live in the same two-bedroom
apartment which they rent for 60 [ __ ]
years all right
they have the same telephone number the
same mailbox the same [ __ ] parking
spot the same mural on the wall I just
saw it Mad Men reruns okay it's like
un-fuckin'-believable and they have a
lot of money and they really Naza
whistles reupholstered it's nice it's
like the [ __ ] Wonder Years I'm going
back to the guy from the one day is like
look but you know that's my pears and I
love them they're beautiful amazing
people but but that's their belief
system creates that sort of outcome for
them did they um did they like well for
sweet when they came out they loved it
you know my dad just died because
obviously became you know yeah sure
listen you ain't lived until you've been
in a [ __ ] Scorsese movie right so my
dad you know was portrayed very vividly
my mother not not so much cuz she wasn't
involved the business and uh it was he
was just like that though he was like a
force of nature my dad like people
people were terrified of him you know
I'm just great to me do you long do you
miss that time of your twenties like do
you miss like I mean obviously we all
miss like the youth of it and stuff but
is there like is there anything about
like just like the debauchery it seemed
like you could have back then even just
in the times it was like yeah we can't
even have that much fun yeah so I mean
yeah no doubt about it right we can have
so much you guys could probably kill
somebody almost you know you hanging out
of window just don't drop them or to
drop the me to pay some damages you know
yeah different world different rules and
in some ways it's a lot better and some
ways it's a lot worse right my assistant
back then our real name was Mona we
still keep in touch about a year ago I
was doing an event in New York and Mona
came just you know you know for an old
times sake and we had this high-end
dinner some ioan con just like you'll
people pants but think it's right and
she sat there and during the dinner and
she's like says you know guys I want to
just tell you this whole meet to stuff
she owes you girls don't know what
you're missing we had so much fun there
wouldn't be one girl at work because it
was never see there's a difference in
sexual harassment and sexual promiscuity
there was if you was harassed you'd be
[ __ ] you and no one was getting
harassed and right now
I'd [ __ ] throw all that my father if
I shoot him okay yeah it was none of
that going on if someone was harassed
they back out the guys would beat it
wasn't like was respect but everyone's
[ __ ] everyone under the desks to the
coat closet and in Saturday it was just
wild [ __ ] Oh cousin in the [ __ ]
basement and I'm Stephen you know it's
fine I was real and they all loved it
but its but if you didn't want to
partake you were not pressured or
bothered that was like the healthy
version of that I don't think the
casting counts couch was it was like
you'd go to Stratton and say I don't
want to spread my legs so all sorry well
you can't or you're gonna be a Lowell
love now it didn't [ __ ] matter right
if you did it because you wanted oh
you're not we loved you either way yeah
it wasn't Paul it was more than two
parts it was just part of your
personality it was you knows good that
ball people types of people that but no
one judged it was just
why it was a [ __ ] circus right that's
very different than a woman who's going
to Hollywood back in the 90s and has to
[ __ ] some fat [ __ ] or LC she
can't get that's [ __ ] up
yeah and that had to stop and I'm glad
it has stopped the problem is is there's
lots of grain between those two places
and and and what happens with any woman
not just this whether it's communism in
the late 50s like the Reds it's always
more polarizes right one place until it
eventually normalize so my hope is is
that it it settles back to a level that
has all the things that it should have
been the me to boom yes and not the
idiocy and insanity that it's so often
projects out to the world when 99
percent of people in the movement would
not want that they would like it to be
it's fair in the middle you know I'm
saying that people had their voice that
the people that [ __ ] up should be you
know but innocent people shouldn't
suffer and also what you did 38 years
ago between two people I have a tough
time of that and less that's proof but
that's just me do you still have people
that reach out from the past they feel
like you owe them money or you know them
debts nothing like that nothing them no
never
do you ever feel like do you ever feel
like a sense of like remorse when you
think that still or or like you ever
feel like karma has like some weird plan
for you or something like that
where's the plan yeah calm is right this
is this is the plan right and it's a
good plan it's a just plan and I think
that uh listen you know there's a lot
people who did worse things than me and
I did a lot worse things than other
people I think on some level I just was
either an ability to write about them
really well mm-hmm and it was a struck a
chord and and in people in Hollywood and
uh and I might try to minimize that my
life wasn't saying no was it wasn't
saying but but we all know that there
are lots of crazy people out there I
think part of it was that the thing
about my life that I think really when
you get down to it but really why it
became a cult fit the movie because
Scorsese is amazing right because he
just is yeah he just is amazing and
somehow who knows what the [ __ ] he does
somehow he has a way of doing things it
just no one else could do what he does
in his domain right yeah he's got a big
budget he's got a Leonardo DiCaprio
there's a nice I mean I
young Ned it doesn't hurt I think it's
beyond that he has a talent that says
how many I was going green it's just a
talent he has but for telling a story in
a certain way or other people could not
do it as well yes that was lucky on my
part I chose Leo that was my choice and
that's pretty obvious - why not because
Leo's [ __ ] Leo he's great right he's
you know as I always say it's better
than Danny DeVito no disrespect yeah I
love Danny - but you know different
Danny whatever deal yeah so um but but
the truth is is that you know in terms
of what happens that I made all these
disempowered kids into Superstars and
that's what connects with people all
over the world the reason young people
love the movies not just of the inside
Lea this is that it's that people came
in that wolf but had no real chance for
success didn't believe they were
successful and he turn around and they
just it was a place where you go and
transform into this person of POW and
live out your dream that's [ __ ] ever
help out a guy that ended up being like
a gay guy and he tried to give you a bj
- like like show you how much he cared
like it that kind of thing because that
seemed like something that could happen
you know you know I can see like if you
empowered somebody so much and I feel
like I'll tell you why I'm not allowed
to be insulted or not I have never ever
been approached by a gay person that I'm
all that offended by that yeah because I
was walking through the airport the
other day and no one ever tried to have
like I was good looking for something or
like no sir I'm your [ __ ] around when
the why I don't give up I guess I don't
give off at that vibe but I think they
did know and know and I don't think I
think ya susceptible to survive I think
also like a gay man would go for another
gay man when they would go for a
straight right I call that in gate
alright yeah I guess I don't give off
the right vibe uh-uh I'm just not
good-looking enough I feel bad about
that other but you know I guess it's
good cuz I'm not gay yeah if I wish I
wish I wasn't [ __ ] awesome yeah do you
think gay guys have more fun than
straight guys I think they do overall I
think so yeah it could be a stereotype
that then it's built in but I I think I
think that once someone's lodged but I
think guys is just [ __ ] hornier yeah
so then two guys would probably
it just makes sense that it would be
yeah you know but who knows
what was the name what was the reason
for uh Stratton Oakmont
what was a reason for the name nothing
sexy I just I just um but bought a
company it was called Stratton
securities and then that company had a
like a like an old lawsuit against that
could have come back and so I had to
change the corporate entity I found
another company called Oakmont they
merged the two to guess I bought it and
then became Stratton Oakmont that was
not happy is there been like cuz it has
like because after that I feel like
people started to take like okay it I
said this many syllables to be a
successful I mean they broke down every
single thing that you did horse and by
the way and what don't think for a
second that when I was I could have I
could have changed the name of Stratton
to XYZ securities I was like well this
convenience a great [ __ ] name you
would want a name that instills
confidence and so forth right but that
was just the luck of the draw but I
would have changed it for sure I was
keenly aware that when I merged Stratton
securities into Oakmont that Stratton
Oakmont sounded better than Stratton
secure but it was just luck that it
happened but you could change you can
pick any name you want you just form a
corporation or change the corporate name
she would do a DBA even doing business
as and you could change anything use any
name do you do is there a that's not
trademarked right or there are a lot of
are there a lot of like you feel like
shady business people that reach out to
you to try to get insight or try to get
information do you know that are you
able to detect that they say my wife's
the best at that arisen [ __ ]
believable she's got like a twelfth
centuries like close she's be honest six
seven she's really go yeah she's a
watchdog she's my [ __ ] be sent she's
my she's my partner and she has this
like a radar she shoots out and she
knows I'm very careful like I am you
know I can tell pretty quickly what's
you know what's so ins that and I'm
listen and I'm a bit of a sucker myself
because I like to believe in stuff and I
have I'm open to being sold to I'm an
easy person to sell to but I kept
someone like so funny yeah if someone's
not legitimate I can tell pretty quickly
yeah but uh and would you still like
work for some of those types of people
like or if somebody off a company
reached out to you and you felt like is
extremely unethical
never you'd say look I haven't I've
walked one many times even if the
money's good I've walked away from a
hundred thousand a day Wow many times
and do you are there companies out there
are businesses out there that
you know susceptible or gullible people
even like myself like you just said like
for some reason like even though
sometimes I feel like I'm smart I also
feel like I'm gullible different they're
different things so once I would be both
you're saying of course so one us do you
know once through your intelligence and
your experience and the other is your
decision-making strategy so there's a
history of all you know we now you make
you don't realize it but we all make
decisions based on these parallel movies
Iran we say if I take action what's my
best possible outcome what's my biggest
pain if I'm right this happens from
wrong you get it if this guy tries to
sell me this [ __ ] if I if he's telling
the truth what's my best outcome and if
he's full of [ __ ] what's the worst that
can happen that's how human beings make
decisions if and what happens with
people like myself who are easy to sell
to and you seem to be the same way the
movie I run on the positive side is
really long and robust I'll bet god this
is pretty if he's right this will I'll
be damned I'll be on the 18th hole of
Augusta [ __ ] victory from this stupid
golf contraption I bought right and my
negative down something I'll run a plan
ll I lose $40 nobody'll I'd want the
negative movie and I run I run out the
positive it's called future pacing my
dad who's the [ __ ] hardest person in
the world so though he would run the
same two movies but it'll run the really
short positive movie buddy
oh yeah make me the [ __ ] but I give
the guy 20 who's still my [ __ ] credit
card information
I'll [ __ ] eyeball my gob seal get
worse I'll put it put the [ __ ] thing
you know break a lot of people pick a
minute and they run out this boy he's
done this one $49 purchase has you
living in a box on the [ __ ] Street
and I'll never recover
wow that's why we have different some
and those lot of people are called high
action threshold people meaning that the
level of certainty that they need to be
at about something funny I'm really
certain that I'm right about this
decision at a very high level of
certainty
versus someone like me or you I could be
it just like man it sounds good
I'll buy him yeah that's why mm-hmm do
you feel like there are there products
out there are things you've gotten
involved in that that are that are there
products out there right now or things
are being sold out there right now that
would be the number one things you would
tell people to stay away from
oh yeah of course yeah a Bitcoin in
[ __ ] currencies yeah that that's my
opinion see you as a salesperson that
seems like a [ __ ] racket yeah yes
yeah because I don't think block not
blockchain technology right the
inflationary aspects of cryptocurrency
are joke to me it just makes no sense it
serves no purpose and I said that at
twenty thousand you know and I still say
it now and I'll you know in listen you
know that's just my opinion and that's
not the only thing there's many things
out there the world is full there's
people out there who sell sales training
programs who are so terrible like they
did terrible salespeople their stuff
makes notes it's idiotic and you know
what they market their way to success so
they yeah they're really good marketers
but they don't know the first [ __ ]
thing about sales training or selling
they're very different things marketing
and sales right so being more of a
period now where sales is stronger or
marketing a stronger overall you feel
they're always both always required but
we live in an area where and at a time
right now where you could sell to to
raise video in other words you can
carefully manage what you put out to the
world by a person could sit in front of
a camera and do 25 takes in front of a
camera to get his tonality this message
just right and follow a script put that
person in a real world sale that fall
apart in two seconds right so you find
some unscrupulous people out there who
use videos to sell products and other
[ __ ] when if it was being sold without
that okay but the good news is those
people I believe it's not sustainable
and that people will eventually adapt
and we'll figure out sooner or later
right um then but also the same told me
you feel also good it's the same thing I
just said you can be used for good right
you can do the same thing if you could
be terrible at persuasion and learn how
to do that and sell things and make a
lot of money help people so yeah what
are products like if people ring your
phone that you'd be like oh these are
things this is not something you should
probably or see any donation to charity
okay any any single donation to charity
I'm talking like I never want to say any
99.999% right
Firecat something like oh these cats
have been in fires and they're like it's
I'll tell you the scam money is going to
charity five percent right ninety five
percent is going in the pocket of the
people who created people with tell them
all because someone any type of thing
that's do with medication on the phone
hmm okay it's being made in China it
sucks and they'll never [ __ ] stop
going you wants to get your number until
you change it so those things I would
never certainly do um you know listen
I'm a big believer that if you get that
feeling in your gut that something seems
off you're probably [ __ ] right right
yeah I can notice that song even if I'm
leaving a place and I feel like I forget
something sometimes I'm like every time
I don't check I'm always right I guess
I'm like [ __ ] I forgot sorry it's a lot
of a lot of stuff out there that you got
to be careful and it's good that to
understand what causes you to make
certain decisions and once you know you
could almost isn't how you make
decisions you know do you is it tough to
navigate since you like have such a you
know a long time I like doing business
and business acumen and sales acumen is
it tough to like like emotionally when
you get into like relationships and
stuff is it tough to separate how you
navigate those two things it's a really
good question so I'm you know my second
wife she was but different life spits
ago she used to send me off of all the
reasons I hate you and I hate you for so
many [ __ ] reasons the one reason I
hate you more than all trumps and more
was that when we would argue and we
would have dissing you were just so
[ __ ] persuade so I say okay I guess
and and I was actually touching I was
right but you were so [ __ ] good at
persuading I just always gave it it
turns out I was right shows that just
drove me [ __ ] crazy and I always say
when I teach the system I teach this
called the straight line I say don't
straight line your [ __ ] wife you
don't saying is there's always leave
laughing anything yeah yeah just because
you can just persuade someone don't
always do it you know do you feel like
your first wife or your set like you're
on your third wife now he's your third
marriage sorry not on your third wife
but hope him on or as much as possible I
know huh that love her and she's
beautiful so do you uh do you miss like
your first wife ever my first wife was
an angel he was she was an angel she was
an angel and and you have
went into that making it was it
different you making those decisions
like were you more like it was the same
me but she was just 22 and uh you know I
just I loved her death she was gorgeous
farm walk mean much more than the girl
is actually pretty in the movie but she
was down they bade her look not as
pretty but uh she was a beautiful girl
sexy not not tremendously intelligent
like that wasn't her thing you know she
was a hairdresser but she was really
nice
got a good heart and I I [ __ ] her I
just [ __ ] her over yeah I did I did I
uh I went through a time out I don't
think any woman at that moment of my
life would have been enough because I
wasn't enough for myself and I was
looking for an answer outside myself so
I would always you know I mean I did my
best dating after I married her so hmm
probably a good thing what was like some
of the hardest things to hide like when
you were running around in viña cuz I've
been a philanderer you know what was
like some of the tough things like let
me by let me just a lab but but I would
never want to be with hub versus to my
current wife right so my current wife
represents the best of everything right
if I don't said I'm dead no but it's the
truth though so but the point was I just
she was an angel of a human being though
yes what was it tough running like as
your as life started to get more height
and he started to get more money I mean
with more money obviously more
opportunities came around there were
more women around save didn't get crazy
like hiding things like from it must
have gotten bizarre huh hi angel who my
second things from your first wife your
first why yeah well yes but I didn't do
a good job of it always you know and I
think that uh I may lose it was it was
insane yeah I went from being a guy at
like my part like junior pawn to Danny's
like Halen's going to the city I'm like
it's two paintings Tuesday night I would
never do a married guy like I'm like
[ __ ] crazy he hated his wife always I
love my wife in the beginning right is
he still married to her no no no [ __ ]
way well first classes that so they must
kill each other yeah oh yeah their first
cousins that's great dude they I never
met a woman that hated him as much as
Nancy hated Danny she's my [ __ ] area
anyway um
oh my god she really hit him but um in
the beginning I was like I'm not going
to the city then I one day I went in
within two months was like four nights a
week and I'm pretty suggestible enough
and I
didn't do a very good job of handling
wealth success and fame the first time
around did not do a good job of it I
didn't I I didn't change who I was it
made me more of what was ready to come
out which was I I could not handle
having unlimited money carnal
opportunity office and every girl was
like it was like whoa was like every
adolescent fantasy being at my
fingertips right now you know nowadays I
would just I laugh at the whole thing I
respect it and I enjoy it and I use it
to empower myself and other people but I
never like it's not this an infant the
movie came out didn't Jamie in any way
but for the better
did you ever hire like have you ever
been so high on cocaine where you
couldn't have sex you know but you hired
other people to have sex like you paid
some people to [ __ ] or not do you think
well I mean just the first aunts like
right every time I took oh yeah yeah mmm
I know one guy Sam Tripoli he's been on
this podcast and he's like notorious for
being able to [ __ ] on on cocaine without
Viagra oh yeah so this is before why him
to come over when he was on cocaine and
[ __ ] somebody they knew like he was like
thank you Wonka that's amazing because I
took occasion
he knows like oh yeah Christ oh it's
like Punxsutawney Phil dude but but but
this is true I'd be like four hours suck
I'm like keep going I'm almost there
like give a [ __ ] hopeful I was hope
always had the I'm a very half you know
glass episode I so I was completely fine
now half empty oh god spines good yeah
I'm like a bee on the phone yeah and
actually did feel good back then when
you when you're on coke but uh some
seasons really sick about that oh well
it's a little bit that's also what
happened man
do you did the cocaine you start to get
a little CD what were you guys getting
you guys getting some good stuff or not
was the cocaine CD or was the actions as
a result of the cocaine oh dude the
cocaine I mean when I was doing cocaine
but we weren't even doing anything that
good no I was probably gonna made it
ourselves doing great cocaine yeah I was
learning we had a connection at that
from a guy at the airport was getting it
almost close to pure you know at the end
I had like a gigantic bag like a kilo my
desk you know I could've never [ __ ] I
was like I was like a pudgy with like
[ __ ] scarf a face phone I used to
have dreamed I would take my head off
right put it in a dryer like a washing
machine like a dryer throw a bunch of
cocaine in there and put it on [ __ ]
permanent pressure [ __ ] you are a sick
[ __ ] to do it I never had that dream and
I really want to analyze you when you
come on my podcast get to the bottom of
that chicken some [ __ ] up [ __ ] but
when me was like you know it wasn't me I
I have an issue with like regulating my
obsessions yeah once I get started on
anything anything business tennis drug
use cheating I have to be the best to do
it I just go for it and I [ __ ]
perfect it bring it to a new level
so it's addiction right yeah and I and
my use of Leslie but Bob almost
quaaludes right it was really the
defining thing for me in terms of drugs
and and I just was [ __ ] great I mean
thank god they're illegal thank God you
can't find them really cuz oh my god
they were just too good how good were
they thing better than you can they were
so good that imagine like it's like
bliss [ __ ] condensed into like a 1cc
main line for like and here's the best
part no hangover afterwards what that
was the pot so you'd be high as a
[ __ ] kite oh yeah come here come on
so you could think actually do it like
have a heart between 7:00 and 8:00 a.m.
go to the office at 9:30 yet you he's
really [ __ ] weird you know some guy
got so [ __ ] high one time he was on
whatever these shitty pills aren't all
these fentanyl's and all [ __ ] up this
dude tied his [ __ ] arms together and
not broke both of his arms how crazy is
that
who did that a guy a white guy a white
guy yeah I must have some [ __ ] long
rubbery arms oh I don't know what he's
got but I'm just saying the pills are
different now now this is the kind of
[ __ ] people are doing at least in your
pills people went to work from 7:00 a
day it's a fentanyl fentanyl of course
I'm fun phantom you know I've tried
everything but yeah yeah we think you're
Christopher Robin it was like I is like
that till the [ __ ] kills you because
it's very depressive on your respiration
makes you stop breathing sorry I have to
speak to this guy to analyze how he was
able to get that high and fetch at all
and and not die and put his arms
together I could see how he couldn't
feel his arms being broken into pretzels
but that's a [ __ ] one for the record
books I think yeah yeah he was kind of
an artist before that so okay I can
explain
you know yeah he's been always kind of a
wild guy yeah um excuse me I got to
interrupt this episode here today's
episode is brought to you by better
help.com better help is a therapist
therapy it's professional and affordable
counseling you can get matched with the
counselor who's right for you I've used
better help calm and it's a way where
you know if you're on the run you're on
the go you're on the lam you just can't
get to a therapist and you need one well
now you can have one in your pocket and
not only is it when you could text or
talk on the phone too but you can also
have a FaceTime appointment with them
there are four community there are four
communication modes text chat phone and
video start communicating in under 24
hours you must be 18 or older available
worldwide scheduled video and phone
sessions easy to change counselors if
needed financial aid is available sign
up at better help.com slash Theo today
that's better help calm
Theo today if you need help and you're
not sure about going into a therapist it
could be awkward it could be
uncomfortable this is a place that you
might want to check out better help calm
slash Theo I'm trying to think of some
other things that I really want to think
about it man ask me anything I'm not you
know you can have no nothing's
off-limits
did you guys I've always had this crazy
fantasy that you guys like did this sex
trick we're like somebody would like
you'd have a woman who would like be
like downstairs with her legs open right
and somebody would jump off of a balcony
or something with an erection and try to
land in the woman you are sick [ __ ] I'm
just trying to visualize the possibility
of success I'm I'm doing how fat would
the woman have to be out him but they
got one how long I never tried it and
you have to have a lot of like safety
features set up you know interests
because we did try that stuff like that
you know all the things that you saw and
then it was always like we tried to
think it out care like what things do we
have to do them what do we do here pull
or the pull this [ __ ] off yeah but we
don't be able to get hurry right
do want to see insane happenings like
you know but it was like the Roman it
was like the Roman Carlson we didn't
want death real if he wanted to be some
maiming but no death no permanent no
permanent things you know yeah so um but
that would be a tough one and we never
really tried that one um but I like I'd
like to serve it just to see it like
someone else do it yeah check it out you
got a lot of young you know you see a
lot of young trend these days a lot of
young kids we try and become famous
they look into this idea of junk the
movie jack jackass try to crazy stunts
right so maybe you could share that with
some of them and well so let's try that
I'm sure you try to break there next
year everybody's everybody's at a level
now where it's like like you top this
page oh yeah yeah do you think we've
reached like kind of like a crescendo in
a way not you know not even close
they've been saying that since the
eighteen hundred's you know I think I
gotta check the yeah it was either 1890
to 1907 either the US Patent Office said
we're gonna close because every mints
been invented it's already been invented
I'm not even making that up they thought
all inventions have been now been made
we can close the Patent Office it was
before electricity hey did you ever get
roped into like a bad business that you
wish you and I gotten into yeah like a
million of them more more bad than good
they like I've failed far more than I've
succeeded you know and that's most
successful people is you always end up
in these bad you don't think that bad
when you try they may just end up
turning bad if whatever reason and uh
the idea either was flawed from the
beginning or your execution was flawed
in some way and you know you're trying
to pivot as quickly as you can as often
as you can and sometimes you just can't
you just gonna shut it down what's like
a [ __ ] what's like a [ __ ] thing you got
involved and what's like one of the
worst things you ever got him worst
thing I ever got involved was a chain of
dollar stores and back in May the craze
in the nineties everything for a dollar
stores right yeah yeah and I thought it
was just about to be born I was like
half in I was like not really mad was
really in the game you know and souls
like oh I got this great deal for you
it's a these Taoist those are about
there's no banker he just needed a few
million bucks
there's 54 stores they're public you
could take over the float of the stock I
was like a cake for a pretty reputable
source so I Gotham y'all I'll do it and
ended up being a [ __ ] black hole I
cost you twenty million dollars and a
lot of aggravation really yeah at what
point do you realize that like an
investment is just an aggravation and at
some point you just need to cut your
losses and find a way to get out of
something like I've even noticed like
I'm invested in like like you know but
like bought into a building with some
friends we couldn't decide what to do
with it in a certain point I'm spending
half of every day that's arguing and at
some point at the stress that it's taken
on me is just
erroneous you know so at some points I'm
realizing like I'm gonna lose you know
I'm gonna lose my entire investment and
probably double what I've been vested
but at some point I just have to get out
of this and cut my losses yeah I think
that typically in those situations the
biggest loss is not even money it's the
time and the aggravation that stopped
you from doing something else so you
know very often people and we all go
into businesses those were
entrepreneurial try something it seems
like a real winner on paper but there's
something about the dynamics the way it
plays out in the real world where it
just doesn't quite work out
it happens all more open than not right
just something with the market of the
marketing something something happens
right and then yeah just this fork in
the road where you could say you know am
I gonna cut my losses and move on or am
I gonna keep trying to make it work and
that's the really the ultimate question
for an entrepreneur right and you know
for me it's gonna have a certain sort of
discipline of like yeah I'll give it
I'll do three or four pivots over six
months I'll set my losses at a certain
amount but but it also just someone's
feeling and I have a it's time to say no
right but when I see a lot and it really
hurts people's on tours they get
emotionally attached to their ideas so
when any other rational person was a
dude just shut the [ __ ] thing down
because you're wasting so much time it's
aggravating you so much if you just
directed this much energy to a different
idea you'd already be rich hmm so that's
what you have to be what really more
careful than an exact formula there's no
exact formula to pinpoint that moment
but you know it's it's again if you keep
trying to pivot
change your approach it's just not
working it's like six months you've
gotta think I'm good look at it do you
think since you expressed also that
you're like I have the ability to feel
kind of like gullible sometimes you know
do you think that if you feel like you
got kind of
tricked or convinced into something that
didn't pan out do you feel anger at the
person or the entity that led you to
that or do you just feel like oh I
should have known better I should have
figured this out differently at this
point in my life I'm not getting tricked
into anything right in other words if um
you know if it turns out that it didn't
work it's not because it was because the
other person was gullible - yeah I'll
see through a bad idea really quickly
but I could be wrong as well a lot I
could be wrong just I thought it looked
good but but sighing someone's gonna
pull the wool over my eyes like that I'm
a little bit older and wise and I then I
once was and I I'd like to think at
least that I'm not saying I'll be right
yeah but I don't think it's like
someone's gonna just trick me that
that's not how think a pretty tough
tough gig right now yeah I'm this thing
I'm like if so if you were like able to
like you know back in the day whenever
you guys were you know when you had your
real firm brokerage yeah when you guys
were selling stuff to people the if you
are also like a gullible person did you
ever think like man these people are
more gullible than me or I can really
give you an ability to relate to those
people no no it's just that you know we
call really wealthy people and you know
it was really about they were very rich
they were investing all over the places
another place they were throwing their
money at like it wasn't you guys weren't
calling like a lot of moms and moms none
zero not right no they were you could
wasn't allowed why would we we you know
we were only talking all really well
money people in that money right yeah so
so I said that like that because I'm
saying like it wasn't because we were so
ethical just out why would you like
writers it was the ethics was built into
the system like don't quote anyone
that's not totally rich because they
lack I'm gonna invest enough money right
so we didn't write and there was a
self-regulating system like that right
it wasn't really bad it was more about
like you know your I was an or how
people would simply trust to send
millions of dollars in over the
telephone Wow
without you ever meeting their broker
now or made this is before the internet
you couldn't even track the stock right
but it was happening all over Wall
Street right I just could even track
there was even a website you could then
get off the phone log in to watch in the
newspaper the next day and see so they
had this [ __ ]
cuffing quotes we use actually the guy
hey where's my stylist at six and a half
was like sex yes people would like oh
there's no any check was crazy and um
yes that part was much more there was
much more of an art to selling back in
the day like these people now therefore
I mean they're doing it this is easy to
do with the computers and everything you
guys had to do it well it's easier but
well tap it takes less finesse about yes
well well the point is what's happened
as you sell a lot now through email you
sell through video so what happens is
you can you use other mediums to deliver
the same message and what happens when
you're delivering on video you're
playing both sides of the back-and-forth
and you have these little loops you're
putting in your videos it's the same
situations apply right now it just to me
makes it easier today than it once was I
say the same rules apply and a great
salesperson will still always reigned
supreme in at the end of the day when it
comes down to it you really want to get
someone to spend more than a thousand or
so you got to speak to them on the phone
so there's a limit to what least today
well people will send you a million when
you that when you look at guys like
these guys Gary Vaynerchuk and uh Zito
what's that guy who reads the book a day
oh I love those yeah these these guys
and these guys monkeys are these guys
legitimate Gary's legitimate legitimate
guys Gary's legitimate tiles legitimate
yeah I think he started off the I'll say
I respect time I respect Thai because he
started off probably not but he [ __ ]
skilled to himself up that's all you
could ever ask of someone it like it's
what makes someone a scumbag is when
they start off putting themselves out
there and they're not the real deal but
the other really gives someone credit to
that but if they did it not then skill
themselves up and become the real deal
so Thai evolved himself what he reads a
Booker then I don't really know but
that's in crime though he's fast i but
he surrounded himself with people like
Alex mayor brilliant
NASA scientist so toy surrounded him
someone built a net you get it don't
with killers you know my hats off to him
Gary's are is a real player Gary's not
but though you name two legit ones it's
like a million illegitimate right
you know I mean more than you could
[ __ ] count yeah I don't even know
something
that are out there Nick do you know any
those guys that are out there we had a
question where a guy named one okay
let's go to that and this actually came
from UFC veteran Alan Belcher let's say
you were in a UFC fight I may be saying
your fight grant cardone
you how would you sell that fight that's
really funny
well I think I think grant has done a
really good job because somehow he's
managed to create a controversy between
him when not exist mmm like he posted to
put some really strange I never listen
so I thought up until about a year ago I
was completely disengaged from my brand
I was working at one company a major
company that had retained all my
services right so it's kind of
disconnected the whole training and
everything in it right and then over
this time I guess grant was building up
his business and like I did when I got
back into my son was my son is very much
into social media and he really manages
that aspect so grant posted some video
like said of trash-talking me sounds
like I'm like who's grant called don't
even know the guy yeah like saying stuff
about me I was like the [ __ ] so my son
then post something alleged leads from
me saying I dude blob an old man when he
did that grant all his people were like
dude I don't know why you saying that
because I've been through his system
it's better than yours yeah if you look
at his own page where he's similar
saying that but his own page not my page
right and I and I heard I knew it was
out there for like a year I never did
Fanning him [ __ ] okay you know something
you're the top people always say [ __ ]
about you right but then my son made
some comments like some really funny
comment back well it's a great troll
he's got to be he'll just kill you you
know he's really not really sharp like
that and then it was like it was a glue
you know but it was like I said the
fight thing is grant really is taking it
seriously he doesn't know he's fight
with the 21 year old oh I think he's
fighting with you anyway he's probably a
really good guy price said it for his
own reasons at the moment trying to do
whatever it was trying to do he probably
could take it back I'm sure all right
but he actually is coming on my podcast
oh wow like someone reached out to be on
soon yeah so I have nothing against Greg
but if you had to fight him no how are
you gonna sell that alright well I said
you did can you create commerce like we
actually eat each other
I'd play up the fact that this is just
tremendous [ __ ] hatred and Warner bus
is not leaving this ring alive someone's
gonna [ __ ] call the [ __ ] ambulance
call the [ __ ] Marie call the [ __ ]
National
in God because I promise you on the I'm
[ __ ] training finish with my last
[ __ ] dying breath you are not leaving
this [ __ ] ring look like that sort of
thing yeah and he's like yeah you're
already [ __ ] dead I already have your
[ __ ] dad come on
I've been training [ __ ] Royce Gracie
yeah yeah give you do you is there you
know they have this fight out there that
um Tom Cruise and Justin Bieber may
fight did you see this yeah I think it
was a joke that's Oh Justin Bieber said
that Tom Cruise would kick his ass right
which I'm sure is true but Justin B was
pretty cool by the way right yeah no
it's a bad rap I think it's a cool guy
right now I think yeah yeah I think he
seems like an easy I guess
I come all don't [ __ ] do you do
Placido you know Tom Cruise a
Scientologist right right so is grant
oh great [ __ ] they're [ __ ] like I
might if I just I might just die I might
just disappear or something if it like
if it went the wrong way that fight side
that day I brought you know something
before I could dog [ __ ] on my lawn let
him win yeah but what if Tom Cruise in
Justin Bieber fought I mean I think Tom
Cruise would kill him you do yeah Wow I
think Justin Bieber would think so too
oh I think me way I think people could I
I think Justin could take him really
yeah and people said because Justin has
that I mean you got to think of he's
what 25 years old I understand I know
but this Justin said he's got that dad
strength right that's a justice and then
also he does all his own stunts he's
[ __ ] pretty built Tom Cruise yeah I
always wanted this do you think any of
that [ __ ] is true does any of it carry
into real life when these guys train for
the [ __ ] ship and they like when they
could do all the swords right are they
just doing it for two weeks and then who
knows right no no but like does I bet
you some of them become proficient at it
because you captain a train they'll put
you with like the top Navy SEAL or a guy
with Rob McGraw so it's like you know
when you're going and in that situation
it's not gonna be where you're just
gonna leave without any skills and the
sort of person that you say I like that
[ __ ] I'm gonna actually keep doing that
how many I bet you know a lot of those
guys ended up becoming experts what I
just wonder how long that training is
how proficient people are in it you know
I know in some cases it's [ __ ] long
and very proficient I think like for
instance even example like I read an
article recently about in Saving Private
Ryan Steven Spielberg made every actor
go through [ __ ] boot camp like the
most
hard disgusting freezing cold hellish
spooky and every after including Vin
Diesel himself said I all made a
petition that [ __ ] it we're out except
for one actor who said you [ __ ] you
stay you know less Tom Hanks really
never like [ __ ] if Tom Hanks
the [ __ ] number one great great actor
we all [ __ ] and they all [ __ ]
sayin and he stayed Tom Hanks time all
to stay and they all said was the best
experience of their life wow I was
respected Tom Hanks a lot of than that
one yeah yeah do you think like haven't
spent time in Hollywood and stuff now do
you find that do you think Hollywood is
like the biggest [ __ ] salesman of them
all or once I think just like I mean
they just use I mean it's just it's so
unreal a lot of people in Hollywood gets
it right they really get it right and I
think when they get it wrong they really
get it wrong and I think that they're
also in a situation where there's such a
voracious appetite for content that by
default you're gonna be really wrong a
lot because you end up with this lowest
common denominator conduct you just have
to be punching out content it almost
becomes like how much [ __ ] can we throw
against the wall to get a hit and I
think that and that's almost like when
Netflix don't invest in a lot of stuff
and then just so you know one thing
banned then we'll keep going that's why
they have once these little pilots or
one season and they do a short form
thing if people like it then they'll
expand on it but I don't anything fun to
met I don't think listening I don't
think Hollywood attracts the smartest
people in other words I think they
travel arresting they track the most
creative people in fact dreamers create
yeah all levels but I don't think it's
necessarily the smartest people and the
greatest salespeople the great companies
the sustainable they will bring in
people who great at that and make sure
they don't put the wrong guy running the
studio that's so the ones that do great
like this guy Kevin Feige from from
you're running the whole Marvel I didn't
met because a [ __ ] genius yeah yeah
you asked me because you could not have
that level of sense and not be a genius
and not what you're doing do you think
that in looking back and meeting
different like CEOs and people that are
running different groups are the people
that are successful they there's at a
certain point there's you know it's not
just luck you know that I don't think
it's ever luck elegance ever luck for
sustainable situations and it
lucky for a short period of time someone
that's sustainable I just did a you know
Logan Paul yeah okay right people would
say oh he's gonna dummy that he's smart
he's a smart kid and when you really
talk to him okay you'll see the strategy
so yeah anyone could go on and do a
couple of back flips and crazy [ __ ] but
when you really sit down and talk to
people who were really killing it it's
very like you know you think Kim
Kardashian is stupid
she's [ __ ] brilliant how could you
not be and stay on stay relevant for
that long right anyone could get it once
but sustainable you got to be smart yeah
and hard-working we got a question that
right here let's check this out what up
the out what up Jordan gang gang just a
quick question for Jordan were there any
like fallacies in the movie that you
wish wouldn't have made it in there or
on the flip side if you want to go the
other direction is there anything that
you guys might have gotten into in real
life that couldn't make it into the
movie because I have you know Hollywood
rules so on the first one this thought
there's a couple of things in there
obviously right like that um you know as
I see where I punch my wife in the
stomach and never I never looked at a
hand to my wife like that in one vial
ever shake or a little Rocio m1 my last
I got sober we were on the stairs and I
kicked out wall how she was trying to
stop me from like killing myself I was
you know overdosing right but it was
like I turn around walk it was there's a
very different very different so in fact
when we took I'm not saying the first
one was good but it's not the same thing
right and that's Adam the movie came out
with my ex-wife playing on we took all
kids together to see them film and we
said this and this is not sure we never
dad this is true we did this as well so
he just sort of told our kids what was
there you know what was sure was not
sure that was one thing that viscerally
bothered me because I would never do
that I think that the biggest thing that
happened there that was untrue that was
problematic for me in terms about the
message it sent
do two things one was that the scene
when I walk into that little firm and
it's like a dilapidated hole in the wall
and is obviously something wrong there
and Leo as me looks at the matters is
this is legal and the guy goes well you
know God do you think that's not what
they said to me they said of course it's
legal I mean if someone said to me
well I run out the door and I think the
reason that bothers me is because I
think it's important that people
understand that today four kids are just
going out into the workforce just
because a company is operating somewhere
doesn't mean it's legal in other words
there's all these companies out there a
small amount but many out there that are
totally doing the wrong thing ripping
off and they'll say you oh yeah it's
totally dirty people you gotta look you
gotta use your own [ __ ] guts and if
something doesn't add up and then you
know check it out further but it wasn't
like someone just said to me like you
know oh yes it's perfect uh they were
like they said it was like purp not like
you know well you know I run out so
there's one thing another thing was um
you know the way it was like that I
walked in like I was a little white sort
of you know great guy and then the next
scene I'm snowing coconut strip club
that didn't happen it took two years I
understand why Scorsese did it you know
this time collapse but I think it would
be even better so my slow descent so
those are some of the things you know do
you miss like strippers and stuff like
that or that type of environment or not
you feel like you've probably got all of
you could huh got my film thank God yeah
I mean I got my fill and uh my life is
so much better now yeah so who was the
greatest stripper you ever met you think
well you know it was what was it the
greatest one strip right I tried to
marry after all I got as I was
overdosing oh yeah and I went down to
Florida
oh yes right before they put me in the
lamp or not it was my it was Delray
Beach area oh yeah all right
think of solid blizzards a real name is
blaze and and I didn't even know this
but I I actually put her on the phone my
mother now might be my new wife plays
like hi I'm mrs. BA and I didn't
remember to like wrote the book I said
my mother the chap is she's a really
great reader my you know writer so she
was analyzing my pages and she's like
honey you forgot about blaze who you put
on like really you didn't even remember
her place was hot now then once I
remember that I start to remember yeah
and what is it like what kind of what
kind of woman really gets who you think
do you think what kind of woman is
really your type a woman my current wife
is my is the best ingredients she's it
she's not she's crazy she's lucky she's
gorgeous
where'd you meet her soccer mom O'Reilly
field yeah you betting on the games I
was as my kids game
and have you ever bet on your child's
game no but I was like almost from the
field a bunch of times for like King
[ __ ] goalies a hologram get him off
the [ __ ] hit my son was a good soccer
player and some of the parents are the
worst we're the worst sports ever it's
just it's as bad as it is they make that
in the movies it looks like it's just
bad on the field did you start to look
forward more to being a parent on the
Sabbath like it's also it was my
favorite thing in the world to watch my
kids play soccer I would get so
emotionally invested and like [ __ ] you
what's wrong with this getting sucked up
news like I was terrible and and half of
the other parents were just as bad but
me or my New York accent is like oh yeah
my ex-wife is just as bad you know
no it got really vicious and soccers
like that soccer is the most vicious war
for parents because it's fast-moving
there's no [ __ ] it's it's I've seen
parents I [ __ ] you not
I watched a father okay tackle a girl
that was running a five-year-old girl
about the school running out and
tackling the girl and getting the
particular a and can cups the rack
because his daughter was the goalie and
this one superstars like five or six was
about to score for an eighth time he ran
on tackled her hell yeah yeah I love
that did we need that kind of stuff and
here's a young fella real quickly how
old are your kids now and what are they
doing daughter is 25 oh wow just
graduated grad school and my you grad
school she's a psychologist she's
getting a masters and but she's thought
to practice psychology now in the city
in New York um and she's awesome she's
brilliant she graduated top our class
3.9 average mmm my middle son caught her
okay's a wrapper just he's an
unbelievable e'en trapper okay stuffs
amazing as a poet he's gonna be more
famous than I ever was and my youngest
son Bowen works with me
Bowen is his name Bowen Bowen yeah don't
hurry and bone runs like my runs a lot
of my business and he's a amazing
business based 22 he's he just kills it
I don't want be 26 now actually she's 26
and did um buff I don't like I'm sold
she's 2016 85 we're getting older fast
huh she's 26
oh it's a battle territory yeah and are
your children married or no my
we'll probably be the first yeah I
shouldn't say it but like I can't say
who's he a nice guy always wonderful of
them yes
heavy she had boyfriends you weren't
into one one he was just a bit my
daughter's beautiful very pretty and the
sweetest shy like she just always was
the best everyone loves my daughter
she's a great grandchild she's a great
friend she's really just a wonderful
person and she had one guy that just was
old with to self important for my but
she's always chosen some you know not
good guys do you think that ever anybody
ever dated your children to try to get
close to you to meet you or to you know
I think my my kids my I have them my
boys probably use it to their advantage
when they can yeah my daughter was never
in short supply of guys I want to date
her so I would think would just be a
long line like I'm a wolf cub of Wall
Street yeah yeah yeah yeah she said oh
she I think she had some issues for a
very short time she was single and I
think she had a couple of times machine
made the mistake of actually because the
guy was a good-looking guy she maybe she
went out on a date with someone that
turned out just was like oh she was a
conquest - she was my daughter or
something like that you know but she
learned pretty quickly let's take this
question from this young man or woman
what's up Theo mr. Belfort I got a
question for you if both of you were in
your prime coke consumption days how
long would an ounce of coke last if it
were set in front of you right now I was
good for seven grams a day so how were
you good for I don't know how much
announces do but I'm talking snorting it
not smoking it oh yeah yeah I never
smoked yes terrible I would say probably
grams in an ounce there's 20 grams in an
ounce yes
so how much is an ounce like if it's in
this it's like a second those plastic
baggies like this much in a plastic
baggie
okay so positive egg you like that like
this like you like a sandwich bag and
it's full no it's like this like this
about a half inch for so yeah like it
weighs an ounce right reason L or an
ounce
oh yeah one 8.3 grams Peloquin an ounce
last me Jesus Christ dude I would
probably if I was really enjoying myself
it was a kind of a festive time of year
I would say maybe
um I don't know probably two days maybe
so 14 grams a day really I mean this was
like on a weekend I wasn't doing like a
by yourself what that's a lot of code I
mean I would yeah I mean I would
probably be close to dying I would be
laying about your nose at all no dude I
just have a have a lot of space in my
nose for code me yeah yeah I have a
little bit extra space myself yeah there
what did you don't grow back either
probably this part about uh doing coke
was just like didn't make you into a
sexual deviant it made me I would just
kind of touch myself and look at the
internet and then I couldn't get an
erection and then sometimes I would like
not you know what you get in the rectory
except even one man what was his name
Sam triple Sam trip was a [ __ ] legend
Oh ro he used to get paid to travel
around town on Coco [ __ ] I can imagine
so it's an amazing company the way for
him he would do his best I he's that he
should be study by [ __ ] life and he
just cut open his penis in his [ __ ]
blood system down there PA what the [ __ ]
is wrong with it you know did you uh do
you ever tie anything besides your
wiener to whenever you were hard to try
and continue to have sex or to prop your
penis up we tried you know why only one
am i well I mean I just think is when
you're high if you're if you're I not
doing you're straight - yeah because
then you're gonna be able to keep your
Weiner oh yeah but still suck I've done
everything I'm a [ __ ] sick [ __ ]
yeah and anyone who denies being a sick
[ __ ] I bet you're full of [ __ ] human
beings are depraved animals especially
human males oh yeah yeah I'm just bald
off to admit I'm a depraved animal okay
yeah no I wanna throw just off cocaine I
will never ever never ever cheat on my
wife and I would and I would let them on
coke who knows I wouldn't say that I
won't do it but I'll cheat on this it
mate on the planet makes meet with the
prey [ __ ] lunatic you know cocaine
I'll get off and the dirty of the better
the more disgusting the better oh yeah
oh dude I uh yeah yeah you know you real
good
something's the best left on set because
I mean you know I mean Alison yeah you
know I had the pic I have the benefit of
having a movie it's basically
desensitize the world that's a given
what my I'm possibly capable of right
but even still there were some things
and one of the questions they they
didn't leave that in the movie was the
bachelor party the level of depravity
was just so extreme that you know I
think people are still missing there's
like 20 years okay and they had a lot
more boy
and stuff back then too didn't they it
did a lot of women a did and I prefer a
little bit myself yeah I don't think I
don't like the whole you know shave
completely thing I feel like I'm like
robbing the cradle
yeah you feel like a PDF file yeah so
this is a little shady oh yeah
now what about this do you um do you see
guys out there today do you get jealous
of like kind of the younger generation
like when it comes to like dating and
their opportunities for like dating on
apps and stuff like that or you know
it's a good question I think it's a
mixed been some level I can imagine I
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] online but you know
kind of sucks that you can't go to old
bar anymore my friend everyone's scared
to get like in you know in trouble with
me to door that's [ __ ] up you know I
mean like I've I'd have my son's friends
like he got me too he almost lost he
once got thrown a neva out of a Stanford
for that for a girl he was totally it
was [ __ ] and and thankfully he got
you know it got righted but it's
dangerous out there but kids they can't
you can't like used to be the best place
to meet a girl was in the workplace yeah
and that was it people would fall in
love my wife always says that she loved
it blue and she was my wife's not young
she's you know she's 52 right she's
Amish she's the most beautiful
two-year-old you ever met right sounds
hard to me it's not and I would meet her
if you pass and ahead yeah you and a
half of town right would you let me take
her on a date if you passed away I would
I'm a nice guy all I would want her was
to be happy yeah that's all I'd want
first if I passed away okay but I don't
think she would because she's she's not
she's very she's like an indoor cat yeah
you know I mean she's not she's the sort
of person that she likes to be alone
more than be with other people she knows
who told me you would be got them
remarried because you just can't be
alone I don't know if that's true but
stay partially true yeah I won't do it I
mean I want I won't even try to talk to
whoever you want me well I'm not gonna
do anything I don't know I haven't said
this this is hopefully you buried it uh
you know if you ever been married have
any kids
really how old are you I'm 39 so I'm an
adult but I don't be shooting blanks at
oh no I don't think so
I just haven't really tried to get the
kid yet mmm you know I think about it I
just you know just have a lot of work to
do still I feel like it's still a little
bit unsettled maybe yeah you [ __ ]
together yeah I think it's coming along
we're getting close you know sometimes a
first
I feel a kid in the back of my nuts he
what I'm saying aching to come out yeah
let's get some more questions that came
in Nick yeah we had some patreon
questions too young piece says what did
friends and family that you know more
personally have to say about the movie
did they think Leo did it justice or was
he off Oh people people Jenya generally
loved the movie and the betrayal yeah I
would find you know some people oh you
were even better that's cuz if I want to
ingratiate themselves yeah Leo did an
amazing job he should have won an
Academy Award for it so yeah I can't
believe that he did he'll do people then
think you were in other movies too like
they're like I saw that movie uh what's
the one where he's the airline pilot oh
yeah catch me if you can
yeah does he think like the are they
sometimes like oh wow I saw you in that
movie where you get busted for the
airline last week that was in um
Australia right and my son was
graduating from college went to college
no straight right it's the old from down
them and I get into a cab and there's a
woman the woman in the cab
she's not too lady it's an uber she's
gotta be you know late 50s and she's
wearing like a sleeveless muumuu type
and she's not the extra like you know
you
speed bag on the back of moms that's
sort of like doesn't look to really have
a [ __ ] together that in that people
level like you sorry I'm not I'm like
you know I would say on the frickin
stanford-binet IQ test you probably
scoring just over 65 guests okay
the looks can be the senior she's giving
a raucous nice until about three minutes
into the ship she turns neutrals are you
playing something and myself oh yeah
he's very famous and she's like I knew
it
just what do you think miss for I'm he's
ago he was in the movie uh the wolf
fault what and and she fires you know
Leo DiCaprio twenty minutes later she
goes the wolf of who but Leo like
Titanic do you know him yeah so and she
couldn't quite grasp the concept mr.
Muppet huh unbelievable I got correctly
always the three of us we won't that was
I did that just happen like we couldn't
write can I
your phone number really way dial-a-joke
you know
and she was sweet a bad but it looks
really odd it was like she couldn't
quite put together the whole thing that
I wrote a book that became a movie and
the most famous movie star chose to play
this thing I'm not a movie star um good
gosh that um you know I think that I
appreciate my fans more than anybody so
I can't understand how you could
possibly be famous be outdoors and
someone asked for pictures they know
yeah I can't understand how you could I
would take a picture with anyone because
without your fans or nothing right I
don't get that right and it matter how
often that how shady I feel even a rush
on your walk with me okay I never refuse
anyone a picture because I think it's
[ __ ] up yeah it's like without the
people to love you or to respect you we
are nothing right right yeah no I agree
I'm just wondering it you know I knows
everyone knows it's it's me and the wolf
it's a very clear like association that
that's what it's about right do you feel
like you're famous for being a crook
ever do you ever feel that I think that
in my in my earlier days like if someone
had asked me that question well you
probably have no agenda for asking that
to me you really want to know how I feel
inside right it would be easy for me in
the early days of this journey to feel
to have some Saint feel bad for five
weeks about that I might [ __ ] people
think I'm a crazy I don't mean I know
you know I know you know I know you know
100 percent just not that sort of person
right it's a good question
the answer is probably some people do
and I feel bad for those people because
it's so much more than that like so much
more complex and that's really just
really not even giving Scorsese Leora
liked itself good enough look about what
really happened right so it's really
about how those people view you don't
listen
everything in life is just it is what it
is and the meaning that we apply to
something gives us all beliefs about
that situation if you're that [ __ ]
myopic that that's your
good luck going through life that's it
that's you probably of you on everything
that is no black and white so do you
feel like you robbed from the that you
do you ever feel like if you robbed that
you robbed from the rich and gave to the
poor did you ever feel like or do you
ever feel like that and never like a
robber
I never was deluded to think that it was
right right okay I clearly 1000%
justified that they're rich so it's okay
right it's not okay it's just not okay
but that was the rationals and I justify
that sometimes in my head you do but
it's not it's not right but but you sir
it's certainly but by the way again
there's no absolute right or wrong on
the scale of wrongness taking a poor
person's last thousand like the worst
[ __ ] crime you could commit a guy
who's worth fifty million and he loses
200 grand that guy's gonna recover and
probably should learn his lesson not
doesn't make it right right they're very
different things they're very different
and that's and I and I on bathrooms high
pasteurization for all it was worth to
keep living my life while I was doing it
yeah well I'm sure at some point you
probably couldn't stop huh
well yes but not for the reasons you
might think there was at a certain point
you almost you not that you lose sense
of right and wrong but you'll line a
morality move so profoundly like things
that you would once think but terrible
no long as everything becomes gray and
then you like feel like it was many
times I felt like it moves I was on this
ship that had sailed that I was like a
passenger in the journey of my own life
and no longer empower my own decisions
that's a cop-out but I felt like that I
really did feel like that so much do you
ever throw like a bunch of money off a
mountain or anything worse than that
I've I probably launched and foul on 1
July for if he took hunt a stack of
lunch at 10,000 and launched it into the
ocean on bottle rockets to celebrate
July 4th 110,000 I hunt no 10,000
hundreds I just for no [ __ ] reason
launched money into the ocean yeah yeah
yeah let's add that money back now yeah
what do you mean oh I'd love right I
mean yeah look I'm gonna keep the faucet
running around here I don't think we're
that far from the beach do you uh what
kind of what type of savings do you have
now did you save money away everything I
had I gave back and started again now
I'm well thankfully I'm doing well were
you worried at some point or did you
always feel even like at that point like
at a certain point you realize I have
this
gift I will always be able to survive I
always knew that but I don't mean in
your Mari don't worry I always worried
back then I worry now my part of my
strategy success worrying I worried
myself into action yeah I'm a warrior by
nature some I wish I wasn't that's how I
motivate myself and make sure I always
get myself to do the things I have to do
each day you don't feel like doing them
it's always easy to do what you want to
do I do what I don't want to do and
that's part of being successful and
being an adult and I worry not gonna
don't have money I don't I don't think
it's about that anymore it's much as
about I'm building a business and a
legacy and I employ a lot of great young
kids who were really psyched about what
we're doing the one thing that this my
business rep about 35 40 employees and
growing fast right I'll probably 100 by
year's end right and the one common
denominator in that company knows that
every person we touch is getting the
deal of a lifetime everything is good
there's not it's never about let's get
it so it's all about giving value we
people love us if you go to my wall like
the people who invest in my programs in
a delta they're like it's the results
ridiculous like it's like i under George
for stuff I probably made a mistake with
that retrospective dude Jeep because
there is a natural sweet spot which is
fair for all sides but the the journey
that we're on is about giving massive
value and making money as a result of
that not the other way around
do you ever think there will be another
movie made about you that kind of shows
the back end of your life you know there
was two movies made about me some was
boiler room he was based on my my firm
which is a loosely Bay and the wolf of
Wall Street you know I I couldn't
imagine because I think my life is
boring right now relatively and people
was a you to live as life is so
courageous things keep seemed I'm always
know things seem to happen to me like
whatever I think I wrote a book it
becomes a [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] ever
like let's just say that when it came
out that Leos and was like it's fake
it's like he was always like it figures
and that not surprised this have and I
you know and I don't plan that [ __ ] yeah
I really don't who could um I don't I
really doubt it but you know you never
know me I'm on a great journey right now
and um I think I have a lot I think I
have a lot to offer the world I really
do and I think that III think I gotta
figure it out I think my values right
now are really perfectly aligned to make
a lot of money as a result of giving
massive value and I think that that's a
big that's a cool thing yeah and I think
that's congruent with who I am and I
think that there's people that worked
with me right now my son being one of my
step many great staff members that are
like partners in the company I believe
in spreading the wealth I haven't
feeling negative push this far more than
I ever would and I'll be more of a
figurehead on their journey and doing
what they need me to do like cuz I need
to do a podcast my son got me to do that
podcast I think I'm saying I love doing
it but yeah but I think that this is
about the company's far beyond me right
now and my greatest hope is that people
and their rise up and replace me and I'm
just you know he's I'm gonna push out a
wheelchair right yeah that'll be amazing
are you sober these days or no sober I
drink like I never was a drinker right
so I would gladly have a glass of scotch
I probably take three sips if you got
lucky I'd finish one shot I would never
do more than that's not who I am right I
don't do drugs
because like and I don't do them I'm not
against them
I lost the privilege yeah like drugs
like a privilege you know people can do
it and responsibly and have fun because
now fun but once you lose once you cross
over you lose that ability I cannot do
them north the dark arts brother right
yeah yeah it gets deep really deep yeah
boy I'm not a nice guy
actually I could be nice I'm just not a
good person on do one of my buddies
would put on a diaper and go on the
dance floor cuz even [ __ ] himself I
understand and it doesn't seem like that
irrational to me I think it's a
prophylactic measure that makes good
common today it's respectful like kudos
to the eggs it's better than shooting on
the floor else's line up and I don't put
a [ __ ] diapers that's a party good
dude
what else we got Nick any more questions
on here they want to go through anything
you want to ask no this is fun this is
my good boy one time I would love to
hear you on his because he could oh yeah
I want to come on my pockets what could
I'd love to have you on my pocket yeah
we'd love to come on they're coming down
like next week or something
we'll just think crazy okay great yeah
we cool uh yeah I think a hundred
stories never there before you do with
Tandy living I'm in like your Manhattan
Hermosa Beach right on the ocean
you see my whole case my comes pretty
cool I got about fifty forty five people
working for me right off that scene with
4045 and they're all in this one house
so I live on the ocean
I took the house right behind me and
they all there and they're just the most
awesome people all millenials people
don't think Millennials work off I don't
know my Millennials a [ __ ] animals
really oh yeah yeah they're like just
empty awesome you know great staff
that's my girls I have these young girls
worked with this so [ __ ] shop Jesus
they're like [ __ ] killers these girls
they're dangerous huh dangerous have one
girl I yeah - ever - at a duo Rachel and
me right you know Rachel's like [ __ ]
a brainiac she would [ __ ] smile
loving it me is like well fire first off
I'm like me you have that cuz she's
headed like a whole diploma like you
want me oh no I'm fine with that
they're amazing um to me I find that
when you have a sharp girl
I think the female mind in some level is
more organized your average I agree just
put it the way the Y and like
hunter-gatherers versus killers right so
guys are great at some things and it's
of course this is just a big mesh mash
there's always say there's always
exceptions but I agree I think women are
organized these girls I have there
they're just like [ __ ] that they do
[ __ ] I could never do like they could
make what they both came in at low
levels and I rose them up like rubber
book you're in charge of this [ __ ] you
know the [ __ ] is great and my son is
the spiritual leader of the moisés I'm a
brilliant young cat I got a great chrome
yeah it sounds like it means I'm really
excited about
I love them they're great they work
really odd um do you like to me one of
the scariest businesses these days seems
to be the news right English do you feel
that like it's changed a lot
yes it's a stroke it's not the news it's
[ __ ] I every night like the East have
a well care it's used to seem like they
cared about our well-being like it was
some general care for our well-being
it's so [ __ ] toxically terrible right
now you can go on for hours about this
but I mean number one the days of like
Walter Cronkite and I long for those
days people on CNN a lot of [ __ ] junk
I mean like a saying [ __ ] that like
if you're gonna my prom is not what they
say yeah
just say that you're not a newt you're
an opinion journalist and then hey dude
like Rachel Maddow you're Rachel Maddow
you're liberal
good let's hear what you say you're
entitled to your opinion and you could
you could say whatever you want because
everyone knows that you're in opinion
journals that's who she is and that's
healthy okay Sean Hannity the same thing
yes making no illusions of who he is
right right but when you or talk a call
someone if you're gonna go out there and
pretend you like Don Lemon whoever his
name is on CNN saying you're that's not
a journalist shame on him for that's not
right that is just not [ __ ] right and
it's fools people because you know I'm
not saying he's even right or wrong
right that's not nothing to do with that
but you're not a journalist you're not
right you're not a journalist you're a
muppet at that point you don't have any
agenda this yes right so and I think
it's terrible it's scary it's very scary
and I and I think it's really sad this
is I voted for Trump okay
mostly because I and I like strongly
believes in this economic policy and it
turned out to be right because the
economy is booming right I don't love
everything he says I'm a really liberal
guy I think Shockley he I think he's
really liberal too he just does that oh
yeah I think yeah I don't think it does
a good job of explaining himself and I
think the media is not and they kill
know what he's doing kill if the guy
discovered cancer they say he discovered
cancer right and let me just say because
he's gonna control all of us now he's
discovered so it's [ __ ] up hey Grady
never gonna die no your own your souls
all my Donald Trump's it's he's not all
bad he's not all goodies Donald you know
better or worse than any other
politician I was probably better glee at
least he [ __ ] says that she says [ __ ]
that I was like but [ __ ] look how much
thing is one of the reasons why he got
elected is he at least you knew who he
was like a lot of people are like oh I
know this guy's kind of a guy who
doesn't pay his contractor's right I
know he's that guy that guy but other
people are like I don't know who that
person is there's some script that's
been going on for hundreds a year you
got it you know what he said he's the
best things ever said was like when the
Democrats are bashing him publicly while
he's trying to negotiate wrangles could
you just lie so I can negotiate more
effectively Regina pretend you like me
like you do you realize how stupid
you're hurting the country why saying
all this [ __ ] out loud so they know in
China just pretend we're on the same
side for it it's like [ __ ] up and it's
and here's the thing it's really not
gonna matter for your ID because they'll
kick this can down the road for another
30 40 years but
some time I don't know what the [ __ ] is
gonna happen with a deficit because
things are just you can't run a deficit
like this forever forever you can't I
don't know what's gonna happen I wish
you know and I think I'm a pretty smart
guy when it comes to economics and
financials I can't the only isn't the
obvious answers to grow our way out to
become so successful economically that
by lowering taxes you become so
successful the tax base gets so massive
that you can pay down the debt I don't
see how that happens mathematically
unless the currency we have got the
value to the dawa becomes cheaper
there's some currency reset which case
to be a global disaster because the u.s.
is the global reserve currency so you
you know just be a country could devalue
their currency the sort of office you
can't do that as the u.s. figured the
global you're the right you're the
benchmark and if there was a reset there
will be ramifications all over the place
I don't know the answer and I don't know
if anyone really does know yes but it's
a scary thing yes so it's almost like
traveling in outer space really it is
and that the fact that that um you know
that he stands up the child whoop saina
Yochai is a peaceful country yeah I've
been in love the people that you know is
there going once again yeah the best
people ever right that's fine economic
wars and you don't respect know they
keep cruises they're [ __ ] you don't
give up don't you you you die in China
then make a soup out of you they sell it
to a couple you gotta keep cruising ah
it's all good it's all good they love
you they're happier there but that's it
dude that's it they're all about China
is very tough to to compete with with
that because you know they want they
need to move up like 10,000 people
willing to build an electric dam like a
plow the [ __ ] place yeah here it's 20
years of [ __ ] water suits yeah
there's a distinct advantage you know so
anyway fits into semantics of my podcast
with a lot of red tape a lot of red
white and blue light a lot of red tape
man no Jordan I'd love to man thank you
so much for being here today
my pleasure
[Music]
little time for me to sell that parking
brake
and let myself
[Music]